category I'm listening and learning. You
believe in the creator like
so this universe like
I mean you know I'm not sure the brother
himself explained to you but we say as
Muslim
belie that this universe must be created
and there's a creator of this knowledge
and the power is something which is well
rooted within us. However, due to our
environment, sometimes some people they
get deviate from that natural
inclination which they are born with to
accept and recognize there is a creator.
You understand? Cuz you know when you
look at this universe, you can see
there's knowledge behind it. There's
order. You with me? You know it's
organized. It's programmed that cannot
come from blind matter. So there's two
options. Eyes or three options. Either
this universe was created by blind
matter but blind matter itself is part
of the create of the universe or it was
created by non-existent thing or it was
created by a creator who possess
knowledge and a power and
ability and wisdom which one makes
sense I mean you can utilize intellect
to come to conclusion
yeah I mean like I give you example
imagine I said to you I have a grandson
I don't have grandson by the way. Yeah.
But imagine I said Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Of
course. Imagine I said no. You ask me do
you have a great grandson? I don't have
great grandson. But guess what? I got£10
from my great grandson which I don't
have. Is that logical? Doesn't make any
sense. Can that happen?
Why?
Yeah. Because so so so we can utilize
our intellect to come to conclusion
about something with certainty even
though we haven't seen it.
I'm not sure. There's a lot more detail
with the creation of the universe
though.
No, I'm saying the option the reason my
grandson is the option of this universe
is created by nothing or by not
existing.
What do you mean? You just told me it
can't happen. No, about the creation of
the universe. I'm not sure who created
that. Yeah, but but it must someone
create it.
Okay. If this universe created, he must
have a creator.
What do you mean? Not sure. It's logical
rational conclusion. I'm not sure. The
universe is old and dead.
Universe what? The universe is very old.
Regardless how old it is, you know,
universe came into existence. It did.
Yes. So if it came to existence, you
know the mention to you is a logical
rational argument which Allah mentioned
in the Quran at Allah said in the Quran
in the the first
Arabic were they create by nothing. Were
they created by nothing? So we
understand this universe must have a
creator. So let us utilize our sound
intellect who created by
nothing existence who create by
nonexistence thing.
What do you remember nonexistence does
not even exist let alone to create?
That's right. So it's impossible for
non-existence to bring something into
creation. So you know for certainty that
doesn't make any sense. Yeah, it doesn't
make any sense that non-existent creates
something. Yes. Nothing out of
something. Okay, that's it. Not
something from nothing. Listen to my
because why? God can create something
from nothing cuz all powerful. You
understand? But that's why I'm saying
not not existing creating something or
the other option which Allah mentioned
the first one who threw out the window.
The other option or the universe create
itself.
Do you think that is logical for the
universe to create itself? Well, if it's
it can't make something, it can't make
nothing out of something. If it never
existed, if the univer if the universe
never existed, it must have something
that bring it into existence. And if
it's already in existence doesn't not to
does not need to create itself. So what
is the last option that we have except
if you have another option or someone
can bring another option other option
that we have which is that's what in the
Quran Allah told us and direct us and
encourage us to reflect upon his
creation to Allah in the
Quran chapter number three Allah
says verely within the creation of the
heavens and the
earth and the alteration of day and
It is a sign for people understanding
people with the sound intellect. Why?
Because you can see there's order. What
is today? Today is Sunday. What is where
is tomorrow? Monday. How do you know
that? By the sunset and sunrising.
There's a order, you know. So you can
see there's order. And there there was a
book was written by an I'm not sure if
you know Peter Atkins. He's a he's well
profound physicist scientist in British
scientist and he was he wrote a book
called the seven rules of the
universe. you know some of his atheist
colleagues they told him this book you
wrote it to help the the theist you are
supporting their claim there is there is
a creator in that book he speaks about
how everything is
corrected you understand so that's why
in the Quran Allah utilize his creation
to prove that he his his existence and
they should be worshiped alone so
looking at this beautiful creation
tremendous creation even ourselves Allah
sent the Quran in Allah
upon the earth there's a sign of Allah's
existence and it should be washed alone
and within yourself you know you know
our body is like factory inside
literally you have a workers doing job
your your everything is connected
everything is order you have a nose next
to your mouth why before you eat smell
food you have a eyebrows above your eyes
why the sweat contain the salt if it
keeps going to your eye will damage it.
You see the liquid that you have in your
eyes is different than the liquid that
you have in your ears. The one in your
ears is thicker. The one here is
thinner, you know, takes out stuff. Here
it blocks stuff coming in the saliva.
Like the saliva we have. Likewise, also
that you have a teeth in our mouth, not
a teeth in our eyes. Sometimes we do cuz
you go buy a lot of food and then you
don't eat, you know. That's why they say
don't buy food with your eyes, you know.
But with you know when you're hungry,
your eyes are bigger than your stomach.
Yeah. your eyes become stomach. So
likewise look so you can see that's why
the Quran it gives you logical rational
tangible proof why Allah exist and
should be worshiped alone and why this
book from God and why prophet Muhammad
is a true prophet why Islam is a truth.
Allah never said to us in the Quran
believe I am God that's it if you don't
believe you'll be punished. Allah brings
many many different uh uh what do you
call it examples analogies to show us
why he's the creator of everything why
this Quran must be from God not from
someone else why prophet Muhammad must
be the prophet of God so before I move
on what have you said so far does it
make sense
yes I follow
yeah is the I mean is a logical rational
we must have a creator okay and if this
the case you can see like I said to you
the wisdom of the creator
And if the creator has a a wisdom,
therefore we never been created without
any purpose. Your eyes has a purpose,
your nose have a purpose, your teeth
have a purpose, your kidney, your heart,
everything. What about you as a whole?
Allah said in the
Quran, do you think that we have created
you without any purpose? Far away Allah
from this imperfection. Because if you
say that we are here without any
purpose, you are attributing
imperfection to the most high, the most
light. Allah said far away Allah for his
imperfection. We have we are here for a
purpose. You know
and I I can make my my point very very
strong by looking at the prophet
Muhammad. I believe in Jesus. Okay. How
this pro a man that existed 1,400 years
ago prophesizing not once, not twice,
not randomly. Now for some people they
can predict and there's difference
between prediction and prophecy.
Prediction for example you can bring
someone who's an expert of football
someone who expert in politics someone
who expert in economy and it will just
do some guess work and predict. Yes. But
prophecy what is so powerful sometimes
when a prophet prophesies something what
you see in reality clearly go and guess
what this prophet is prophesizing about.
Give you example when the prophet
Muhammad wasam was in Mecca he was just
him and like maybe say 20 followers and
he was telling his companions that his
companions they were overpower the
Persians and the
Romans and the Persian the Romans at
that time is like you can you it's
equivalent to America and
Russia the power cuz back in those days
the seventh century the world was
divided into two either you belong to
the Roman Empire or you belong to the
Persian Empire. So the Persian and the
Roman they had a proper army. The Arabs
didn't have proper army. They were just
like attacking each other tribes. And so
a man that was in Mecca, his followers
were scared for their lives from the
from their own tribes. And he was
telling them that you will overpower the
Persian, the Romans. Even some
hypocrite, they were mocking him. And
they said, "This man is telling us that
would overpower the Persians, the
Romans, and we can't even go to the
bathroom. We kept our lives when they
were in Medina historically speaking
from a Muslims and non-Muslim sources.
The Muslims at the time of Abn the
second califites it was very close to
prophet Muhammad the Muslims took over
Persian and the Roman stands here. So
the question how a man that existed
1,000 years ago prophesizing about
something that it was like even there's
American not American British historian
he said about this prophecy he said if
you look at it from material point of
view
as if it's impossible to take place but
it took place
another prophecy you know about
interest you know
interest said there will come a time
when interest will become
widespread widespread even if you are
not involved directly will affect you
know the word of Muhammad wasallam is so
precise because he look what he said he
said even if you are not involved you're
not even involved you know you try your
best stay away from it however we still
affect you now by therefore if you open
a bank account and you tell them listen
I don't want no interest in my account
I'm a Muslim I don't like to use
interest they will still use your money
for
interest so how a man never existed
400 years ago prophesizing about
something detailed not randomly
precisely detailed. Another prophecy
prophet Muhammad wasallam mentioned he
said this the Islamic nation the
beginning of it will be mighty and
powerful and strong and the end of it
there will be a lot of trials and
tribulations and weak and if you study
Islamic history from Islamic sources and
even from the non-Islamic sources the
Muslims in the beginning the the
especially the first fifth century five
centuries of Islam the Muslims were very
very strong I mean the Islamic empire
was from the border of China reached all
the way to Switzerland
You know even there were some islands
belong to the British the Muslim took
over it you know. So the point here is
that uh what do they call it when
Muhammad sallallaihi
wasallam mention about the the strength
of this um and he said at the end of it
to be very weak and look at the Muslim
nation now it's very weak. I mean like
if you kill 10,000 Muslims they don't
care. People don't care anymore. But if
you kill one Jewish man in the middle of
nowhere you see all over the news.
Yeah. You see, you see what I'm saying?
You know that already. You know what I'm
saying? So, you can see how the Muslims
take a very weak, you know. So, how a
man that existed 1,400 years ago. And
when he said that, the Muslim were not
strong at that time. They were. So,
that's what I'm saying. So, the logical
rational conclusion that we have to come
to this man if he was a
liar liar would never prophesy like
this. That's it. So he must be he must
be get he must he must be getting that
knowledge from the one who creates
everything. Cuz in order for me to make
a phone from scratch, I have to know
about the phone in
detail. You with me? I'm with you. Yeah.
Of course. If I'm if I'm creating it
from scratch, I'm going to start from
scratch everything. And no one knows
about the phone better than I do. So
when prophetam is prophesizing, he's
saying that information is getting from
God Almighty. So this another point
strengthen my point why God exists and
prophet Muhammad must be the prophet of
God. Even I give you another analogy or
another prophecy about the in the Quran
that's this in the Quran Allah
said the meaning of the verse we have
made Quran easy to be memorized easy to
be memorized this
claim is compared to his companions.
Okay. Now if you go to Africa, Asia,
Europe, America, you will see Muslim at
the age of 9, 10, 11, 15. They don't
know Arabic language. But they memorize
the Quran in the Arabic language. It's
like imagine all of us here, we memorize
a book, that in Chinese, but guess what?
None of us speak Chinese. What? So you
memorize this book in Chinese, but we
don't know Chinese. You know what I'm
saying? That's why Quran is very Allah
made it easy for me to memorize it. Also
in the Quran Allah give a prophecy that
the Quran will be preserved. Allah
said we have said in the Quran and we
will preserve it. This we have to verify
is it true or not? We can verify it if
the Muslims and the original text don't
you have the original text. We have it
here. We don't have we don't we don't
need paper. We have it here. Why?
Because if the Muslim we can put the
test now if the Muslims and the Jewish
and the Christians bend their scriptures
say you know what let us get read our
scriptures go completely the only one
stay with us is the Quran because our
heart like you know the alphabet English
alphabet if everyone say let us get a
read of the Arabic alphabet written in
written form on a computer we still have
it because we memorize it you understand
that's why no one's able to corrupt the
Quran you know cuz in the heart if
someone does everyone else is like oh
thank you very much it's like imagine
now I say let me get a paper I said you
know what a o u c no a b c d you
understand so and since the time prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam the
Muslims they had scholars only for Quran
they duty and job to stay in the masjid
to go houses outside teach the people
the Quran that's why there's a say in
Arabic language they
say do not take Quran and do not learn
the Quran from someone lent it from the
the mus. You have to have a teacher and
that teacher must
have must have authorization from
another teacher and he goes back to
prophet Muhammad wasallam and put that
on a big scale. Imagine thousands of
Islamic scholars expert in the Quran.
That's why we're not like Christians.
They every day they update the their
Bible. It's like a iPhone. It's from the
Greek. It's from the Greeks, isn't it?
That's when they rewrote it. Even in the
Greek language, there's a lot of uh
differences. Like if you go to King
James and you go to ESV, there's many
passages in ESV does not exist in King
James. Sorry, there's many passages in
King James does not exist in ESV. And
they tell you, if you go to the
footnote, they tell you because the
early manuscript don't have it. Now, for
example, Matthew 17:21. Likewise the
story of Jesus when he was asked to who
whoever uh whoever never sin let him
cast the first stone you know that woman
ador woman the Christians love to to
quote it that story is not true story
and but you know also in the Quran Allah
told us that the Christians and Jewish
people corrupted the scriptures and we
not even the Christian scholars would
tell you
yes that Jesus spoke in different
language you know if Jesus come back now
and he sees is the Bible, the New
Testament that Christians are using, he
will say, "What is this?" He doesn't
know it. But the Quran, we are using the
same book he was
using. What do you think so far? Make
sense? That makes sense. Alhamdulillah.
You see, that's what that's the beauty
of the Quran. The beauty of Islam. Islam
when God create us, he creates the tools
which sound intellect, natural
explanation, which goes in line with his
revelation.
It's like me make a card and make a key.
If I'm going to make a card, I'm going
to make a key that start the car. You
understand? So Allah create us is so
powerful. That's why when we speak to
many people or that's why many people
are except for Islam because one of the
miracle of Islam because in line with
intellect worship one God who is that
god is it
Muhammad anyone that believes prophet
Muhammad is God is not a Muslim. God
Allah describe
himself Allah is one unique
Allah self-sufficient everything is in
need of him he's not in need of
nothing if he get not neither would he
be and there's nothing like going to
Allah he's the creator and we are the
creation you know even another verse
Allah
said Allah No one deserves to be washed
except
him. The ever living the one who always
in charge of his creation maintainer of
his
creation know he does not sleep
about everything that in the universe
belongs to him. So when you look how
Allah described himself in the Quran
even about the Quran speaking about the
seed the life of the grave the hellfire
paradise the outer it's impossible for
someone from the middle of nowhere to go
to come with that detailed
information and let me give you
something which is way stronger as well
you know
Islam came to preserve five things
to preserve five things okay which we
call universal
necessity. Islam came to preserve that
universal necessity. Islam came to
preserve religion. What does that mean
in Islam? Protecting religion and making
sure you're not worshiping a force god
and you're not directing any act of
worship to any created thing or a false
god. It's very important. That's why
Islam if you commit shik which is
associated with Allah takes you out from
Islam. And when you start following your
own desires and society the reason there
of corruption our societies because we
tend away from God. So that's the first
thing. Secondly, Islam preserve
intellect comes to preserve intellect.
That's why in Islam alcohol and drugs
forbidden because intellect is one of
our faculties faculties that we do
utilize to just you know what is right,
what is wrong, what is good, what is
bad. Okay. Third Islam came to
preserve money wealth. It's not just
money wealth. What does it mean? That's
why Islam gambling and interest
forbidden. Gambling interest forbidden.
Likewise the proof what Islam came to
preserve life. That's why killing
yourself and killing people unjustly is
forbidden. Last one Islam came to
preserve lineage. That's why fornication
and adultery is forbidden. Islam. So the
five universal necessities that Islam
came to preserve. If we do preserve
them, we will have a good societies. The
opposite alcohol. Is it good for us or
bad for us? Alpha individually and
collectively. Interest likewise.
Interest making the rich richer and the
poor poorer. Okay. Gambling likewise.
Gambling destroys individually
effectively. Likewise, fornication,
adultery. Fornication adultery re
there's a research was done in Britain
and America. They found that a lot of
crimes has been carried out by young
people. They come from broken houses.
You understand? That doesn't mean every
person who come from broke house is
going to be bad. No. But this what you
need parents. You need a father figure,
mother figure. You understand to raise
their children. No one loves the
children like the parents. But when your
house starting around and having
children and letting the societ
social service or social take care of
it. Oh yeah. Social services. Social
social service. Then we're going to do
the best. Let's be real. Okay. They try.
You know, we appreciate they try and
take care of these children. Sometimes
they're better than some parents, but
most times not. Most times, right? In
very worst, very bad circumstances.
Yeah. That's why exception does not
change the rules. Yeah. You with me? For
example, generally speaking, in boxing,
a man is stronger than a woman. But
there is some woman stronger than a man.
Doesn't mean because there are some
woman stronger than a man who have
changed the rules. Now, yeah. You know
what I'm saying? That's why Islamic
rulings and legislation is not not
because there's group of people, he goes
against them, therefore we have changed
the rules. No, you understand exception
and can be changed. So, so these five
things that Islam can preserve and to
warn against the other ones, alcohol,
drugs and all of that. Not just warn
against it, there's there's a capital to
punishment because when we do these
crimes, we're going to destroy ourselves
and our societies, right? So, a person
might ask himself if this the case Islam
came to give us a good life, good
society, why there some people hate
Islam? I will tell you the answer.
There's two type of people they hate
Islam. Either they are ignorant and
they've been brainwashed by the social
by the main media or majority of times
those who are in charge. They look at
Islam as a threat for their business.
They know imagine I have a banks, I have
nightclubs, I have this and you come as
a Muslim in my city and you telling
people alcohol is not good for them,
drugs not good for them, uh what they
call it uh fornication not good for
them. interest gambling I'm gonna look
at you as my enemy even though you're a
good person you want good for them but
because I have this evil trait that's
why this those who are in charge they
utilize their wealth to make Islam look
bad even though Islam is good for us
individually and collectively the
question you ask yourself how a man that
existed 1,400 years ago who couldn't
read and write is able to bring this a
perfect way of life on the other hand we
have this politician who studied in the
best universities in the around the
world Oxford University Cambridge
University yet they cannot resolve the
problem that we are facing you know
Bernach Bernard show is a Irish thinker
he's an Irish thinker you know what he
said he was not Muslim he said the
problem the problem that we are facing
our now in our time if Muhammad was
alive he was he will resolve it in one
minute
this is an Irish thinker you understand
and he's he's not a Muslim by the way
but he's he's the truth. There's many
non-Muslim historians spoke the truth
about Prophet
Muhammad. Even someone accept Islam,
they become Muslim. They say it's
impossible for this man to be like just
normal guy. No way. Look at the Quran,
his teaching and prophecies, the miracle
and so on. You understand? Look what's
happening our society now, bro. We start
following our own desires. For example,
this LGBTQ, ABC, UF, I don't know what
is going on. They took all the alphabet
letters, you know. They have to give us
some, you know. So
LGBTQ they some some of them they they
change the
appearance because they feel like
there's a man he feels he's a woman so
he goes have surgical operation to
change his you know private party
everything did you know that Allah spoke
about this in the Quran Allah mentioned
this in the Quran 1 years ago Allah
mentioned that Satan Satan said I will
inspire human beings to change Allah's
creation
USB may Allah have mercy upon him but it
was that he died like maybe 8 years ago
he said yes he said look what's
happening he said he would tell them to
change everything and that's what's
happening now some I'll give you example
which doesn't make any sense I said to
you and forgive me I never catch your
name what is your name again Sean my
name is Shami nice to meet you nice to
meet you it's my pleasure and thank you
for giving me your time I appreciate it
thank you Imagine Sean I'll tell you
look I feel I'm armless even though
clearly I have arms but I feel I should
have born as an armless person. I want
you to help me to cut off my arms. Would
you do that? What about someone who was
born a man? Everything is a man but he
feels he's a woman. We go cut off
everything. And you know there's many of
them coming out and speaking out and
guess it say don't do it. But because
the men what do you call
it? What do they call them? They mention
also those secret society. Oh, like uh
Freemasons. Freemason. The Freemasons.
And we believe they are there is there
Freemason. Secret society. Yeah. Some
people they go about it. Everything's
free. Freemason. No, you have to be
balanced. Those who are in charge, those
evil ones who are doing the job for the
Satan, they will not allow it to happen
to speak. They will try to do everything
to shut them down. As I watch the
documentary and I tried to look for it
again on YouTube, it's not there. It's
been removed. It was done by American
channel. I can't remember the name of
the channel. Many of them said, "I
regret it. I want I was 16. I went to my
doctor and I told him I I'm a woman." He
didn't even tell me no maybe there's
something going on this, you know,
sometimes you have different feeling in
your life. Sometimes you feel like you
got to fit in and that was the only way
for those people. I've had a lot of
teenagers when I was younger to
transition and now that they're older,
no, it's they've made a mistake.
It's obvious, you know. say something in
Arabic, we call
it. Allah said the
Quran Allah natural
inclination, natural ination that these
evil ones, they try to do everything to
corrupt us, but they will never be able
to corrupt our natural inclination. I
was watching this documentaries on
YouTube. You can watch it. this a
Swedish couple is a man with a man with
you know so they have a a
child and they have the grandmother one
of the this couple the grandmother is
with them and these two men they say you
know we don't we don't force our child
to tell him which clo he should choose
he can choose whatever he wishes the
grandmother exposed the son said no he
forces him when the boy is going to buy
when the boy is going to the clothes for
the boys the the the so-called father he
would take or m it would take him to the
girls
section. Subhan Allah. You and me. So
you would take him to section and the
fra which prophet Muhammad was also said
every newborn is born with a natural
inclination. His family make his family
make him a Jew or a Christian or fire
worship. There's a study there was study
done university and they done a research
which took them three years and they
spent 1.9 million. What was the study?
Was it the children are they born
originally believe in God or atheist? So
they took children from different part
of the world. They came to the
conclusion that if you leave children
without any prior education, they will
grow up believing there is God and
there's a purpose for this universe. And
the prophet Muhammad was mentioned that
mentioned this 1,400 years
ago. That's why you know alhamdulillah
Islam is not like if you notice baba I
never told you believe Islam is the
truth because I had a
dream believe is the truth because I was
walking down alleyway prophet Muhammad
appeared to me said Islam is the truth I
never said why I'm using tangible
logical rational textual proofs to show
you what Islam is the truth now you you
are utilizing your own intellect to come
to a conclusion you know and if you Any
question any question that you heard
about Muhammad wasallam about him
getting married to Isisha about Muslim
non-Muslims about any question feel free
to ask because I don't want to keep
talking you know I like talking Alian
especially when we drink coffee they
love coffee when we drink coffee we talk
about everything so you have any
questions I'm just here to listen that's
you told me a lot okay what I'm going to
do where's my Quran Quran I'm going to
give you this
book a gift from me. Okay. What this
book is called about the Quran. At the
end of it, he explain the five of Islam.
He explain something about the doubt
against Islam and everything. So this is
a gift for me
and usually I give off invitation to
people. That's why you say you should
become Muslim. Islam makes sense to you.
But I'm up to you completely. When you
go home, speak about the young brother,
your friend who's Muslim. He's a
blessing. You can ask him. All my
questions.
Alhamdulillah. Mashallah. Very nice
talking to you. I'm still I'm still new
to this topic. So, thank you so much.
You're welcome very much, man. Thank you
very much, man.